femmes et filles afghanes du statut
prima facie qui permet aux réfugiés de
bénéficier d'une protection
internationale avons un examen
individuel c'est notamment une demande
d'analysé internationale de human rights
watch et du centre sam elle a un rôle
dont la fondatrice nassim majdi s'est
exprimé lors de notre première séquence
et et nous en a parlé
il s'agit aussi de voir ce que nous
pourrons faire pour que ces femmes
puissent rester dans le pays qui est le
leur pour l'heure que leur sécurité et
leurs droits soient respectés et
renforcer une pression politique doit
être maintenue à l'égard des talibans
les droits des femmes sont des droits
humains non négociable l'enjeu est aussi
celui de la participation des femmes à
la vie politique et publique afghane
aujourd'hui le mois dernier une
délégation de femmes leaders afghane
s'est exprimé à l'onu afin de réclamer
un siège dans les discussions avec les
talibans et au sein du processus de paix
des mouvements féministes tente
également dans des conditions
périlleuses de manifester pacifiquement
à kaboul pour être intégré au processus
décisionnel
nous devons soutenir ces démarches et je
pense se reconnaît que vous avez vu
comme moi voir au moment de
cette prise de pouvoir par les talibans
une femme qui était maire et qui sur les
réseaux sociaux disait qu'elle allait
être du coup en première ligne en danger
de mort puisque quand on est femme est
politique on à double peine
notre premier intervenant tu seras
allison davidiens responsable du bureau
d'onu femmes en afghanistan elle
interviendra visioconférence depuis
kaboul onu femmes continuent
actuellement son action en faveur des
femmes et filles afghanes et en soutien
à la société civile féminine aux
associations féministes les prises de
paroles de personnes basée en
afghanistan sont actuellement très
sensible pour des questions de sécurité
et nous remercions vivement onu femmes
pour sa participation à notre table
ronde ce témoignage sur la situation sur
place et sur les actions menées par onu
femmes sont très précieux je précise à
l'attention de mes collègues que madame
david jean ne pourra pas rester jusqu'à
notre temps des changes à la fin de
cette table ronde mais elle a accepté de
répondre à quelques questions à la suite
de son intervention
nous entendrons ensuite shoukria haïdar
président de l'association negar soutien
aux femmes d'afghanistan qui oeuvre
depuis 25 ans en faveur des droits des
filles et des femmes notamment à travers
des actions pour l'éducation et nous
expliquera comment elle a relancé le
combat contre les talibans qu'elle avait
déjà mené en soit 196 et quelles actions
elle entend aujourd'hui mener nous
entendrons également marie george buffet
députée de seine-saint-denis que je sais
de lui elle a fondé en septembre dernier
un comité de soutien à l'émancipation
des femmes afghanes dont elle nous
présentera les premières actions enfin
notre dernière intervenant sera david
martinon ambassadeur de france en
afghanistan depuis 2018 je suis très
reconnaissante que de vote représente
vraiment c'est très important il a
organisé dès le printemps 2021
l'évacuation de centaines des français
ainsi que près de 3000 argon menacé en
raison de leur lien avec notre pays ou
de leur engagement nous entendrons son
témoignage sur les actions entreprises
par la france ainsi que son analyse sur
la situation actuelle et de levier
aujourd'hui possible la diplomatie
française est votre rôle aujourd'hui
revenue en france je laisse sans plus
tarder la parole à alison david yang qui
intervient en visioconférence et en
anglais depuis le bureau d'onu femmes à
kaboul ces propos seront donc traduit
par un interprète donc je vous invite à
re mettre votre écoute heures
[Musique]
ça va
ce qu'elle nous entends déjà
oui je vous entends des mets toutes mes
excuses j'essaie de
jeu que vous pouvez faire c'est me vous
pouvait m'entendre vous pouvez me voir
vous pouvez la présentation également
merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]
merci de l'occasion de m'exprimer devant
vous aujourd'hui
je vais faire une rotation rapide
comme beaucoup d'entre vous le savent
l'afghanistan
connaît une crise humanitaire mais
c'était un véritable désastre
l'impact de l'aco vide cet
incroyable
crise climatique également qui empire du
fait de l effondrement économique je
sais que vous aimez partager des
chiffres mais ces chiffres sont
ahurissants 24,4 millions d'afghans ont
besoin satis de l'aide humanitaire ou
l'autre cette limitation de 33% par
rapport à l'année dernière l'année
dernière c'était 18 millions de
personnes qui plus est le nombre
d'afghans
qui est en situation de précarité
alimentaire sergente devrait passer à 23
millions du fait de l'arrivée de l'hiver
et de l'accès difficile à ces
territoires plus de la matière dans deux
mois la 5 ans en situation de
malnutrition aiguë et le pit nous deux
également déclaré que
milieu de l'année prochaine la majorité
de la population se rende une situation
de pauvreté d'indigence nous savons que
les femmes et les jeunes filles sont
d'une particulière justement de ces
situations mais on sait que si elles ne
sont pas totalement incluses dans la
réponse humanitaire
cette crise ne fera qu'empirer
désolé
très bien merci alors
nous savons que
la crise humanitaire et économique
afghane ne fera qu'empirer si les femmes
les jeunes filles ne sont pas totalement
inclus dans la réponse apportée chaque
jour nous sommes en lien avec les
dirigeantes et des actrices de femmes
sur le terrain les droits des femmes
doivent se traîne on est l'aliment nous
ont dit que les droits des femmes seront
respectés dans les limites prévues par
l'islam dans ce cas prévus par l'islam
mais ce qu'on constate c'est qu'il ya de
plus en plus de restrictions sur les
droits des femmes dans tout le pays
femmes des plus jeunes filles voilà une
vue d'ensemble des ralentissements de
l'arrivée des talibans au pouvoir
aujourd'hui c'est journée internationale
de l'humiliation d'une violence faite
aux femmes la ville connaît un des plus
forts taux de violence contre les femmes
dans le monde avant le mois d'août neuf
femmes afghanes sur dix avaient connu un
mois un type de violence aux mains de
leurs conjoints et c'était afin le coc
vide le kobe n'a fait qu'empirer les
choses dans le monde et donc
l'afghanistan n'est pas une exception
l'accès au service est désormais plus
limité du fait des restrictions la
mobilité du fait des concessions mystère
également car les centres qui fournit
les services aux femmes battues ont été
fermés un peuplier
beaucoup d'inquiétude
vis-à-vis de leur maintien nous voyons
également des restrictions concernant
les mouvements déplacement des fans
province les femmes ne peuvent pas
sortir sens quant à la marque c'est à
dire un chaperon masculin dans certaines
provinces les femmes peuvent même pas se
rendre au travail ou si elles le peuvent
c'est seulement
pour vous renseigner
désolé pour ce bruit naudinat heures
seulement dans le secteur de
l'enseignement et de la santé beaucoup
de femmes se sont vues forcées de
quitter l'emploi ou le père du pharaon
ces restrictions les déplacements ce qui
a bien sûr durcissement sur la pauvreté
avec l'accès également des femmes et des
jeunes femmes qu'il y a de restriction
il y a dans le nord du pays tout de même
une réouverture progressive suite au co
vide des établissements met
fin
au lycée et à l'université en termes de
soins de santé l'accès aux soins de
santé a toujours été un défi en
afghanistan mais désormais cela est fait
qu'empirer du fait de la réduction des
financements la communauté
internationale et les efforts de santé a
besoin concernant la situation politique
maintenant on constate
aucune femme n'a été inclus nommé au
sein du gouvernement comme de
l'opposition
il ya eu 27 nomination des talibans sept
semaines et encore une fois pas une
seule femme fait partie de cette liste
le minet
abolie et nous constatons nous amener
chez moi de restriction porte
d'accès des femmes à vie politique et
publique les refuges pour les défenseurs
des droits des femmes sont capacité
maximum est ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que nous continue
je dirais l'idée essentielle de juger
les déclarations des talibans à l'aune
de ce qui se passe de la réalité des
femmes en afghanistan c'est essentiel
enfin concernant ce que la france et la
communauté internationale que faire
justement à l'avenir je pense qu'il ya
trois éléments principaux tout d'abord
il nous faut il faut fournir
des forums des endroits où l'on peut
entendre parler les femmes afghanes et
pas seulement en entendre parler
utilisant les plateformes qui sont à
notre disposition pour écouter pour
donner un écho à ces femmes alors alors
voir leur prière à l'intérieur du pays
comme à l'extérieur des frontières
afghane deuxièmement il faut garantir
les droits des femmes soit la
préoccupation de préoccupation première
de tous nos efforts de près munication
de négociation et de plaidoyer
le plaidoyer activités de plaidoyer 30
éclairé je dirais amplifié par
l'expérience des femmes afghanes sont
essentiels dans les prémices de notre
engagement avec se résigne de travail
nous avons voulu fixer je dirais un
niveau de discussion et d'engagement
très clair et enfin nous voulons assurer
un flux de financement constant pour les
organisations de la société civile des
femmes qui travaillent sur le terrain
pour aller à l'assaut de ces femmes et
satisfaire leurs besoins on sait que
seulement 1 % de l'aide publique au
développement va même ces organisations
de défense des femmes pour locale la
seule manière de changer cela c'est
d'investir stratégiquement
volontairement intentionnellement dans
ces organisations ces associations sont
des moteurs de mouscron gré de
transparence dans tout pays et
l'afghanistan invasion reste il se sera
particulièrement essentiellement faire
progresser cette question si nous
voulons garantir que il y à une
redevabilité une transparence de la part
des autorités il faut que ces
organisations ces associations et les
moyens de faire le travail essentiel qui
est le leur ou désolé pour les petites
difficultés techniques au cours de cette
présentation si vous avez des questions
je serais ravi d'y répondre
merci infiniment madame pour votre votre
présentation était extrêmement clair et
je pense qu'on ait fait votre votre rôle
est essentiel et et j'espère que on va
pouvoir également porter votre votre
voix à l'extérieur à l'extérieur de
votre pays chers collègues si vous aviez
des questions pour pour madame pour
qu'on puisse pour madame david hay en
avant qu'elles ne nous quitte
allez-y
j'aurai une question pour vous madame
vous avez
évoqué la situation sanitaire situation
de la pandémie en afghanistan j'aurais
aimé en savoir un peu plus lorsque nous
avons évacué nos personnels et nos
partenaires nos amis en août aucun
d'entre eux aucune d'entre elles n'était
positif au qu'ovide en arrivant en
france donc j'avais l'impression que la
situation du coc vite c'était locaux
vides étaient terminées en afghanistan
vous semblez nous dira le contraire est
ce que vous avez un peu plus
d'information
merci pour cette question
je suis ravi de constater que les vols
d'évacuation
que les passagers n'étaient pas tant que
ville difficile de vous donner des
statistiques concernant la copie dans un
organiste ans mais on pense que l'on va
connaître une quatrième vague du fait
des déplacements de populations qui ont
lieu depuis quelques mois qui plus est
le secteur de la santé est totalement
[Musique]
paralysée du fait de la surcharge de
travail la communauté internationale
souffre bien sûr de la copie de
l'afghanistan également ce n'est pas
terminé qui plus est notre la population
afghane n'a pas totalement et bien sûr
vacciner nous sommes à moins de 10
pouces de vaccins encore il faudra
regarder de près les statistiques mais
malheureusement lacauve il n'a pas fini
de faire des ravages dans notre pays
merci infiniment madame d'avoir été avec
nous et pour votre action en faveur des
femmes je sais qu'en plus en effet votre
prise de parole quand vous êtes encore
là bas est compliqué j'espère que vous
même ne craignez rien
merci à vous et j'espère que on
continuera à voir de vos nouvelles
n'hésitez pas à nous alarmer quand quand
on en aurait besoin
je vais passer la parole
à notre deuxième un terrain intervenante
donc shoukria haïdar
allez-y
merci
de m'avoir de m'avoir invité à cette
table table ronde pour expliquer la
situation
des femmes afghanes surtout dans cette
période
campagnes
de violences et
entre les violences faites aux femmes
malheureusement nous gagnons c'est le
pays qui on peut dire aujourd'hui c'est
de la pluie et même de violence exprimée
et s'exercer quand elle donc tout les
niveaux
j'ai écouté les interventions de nos
amis qui sont parlé auparavant
j'ai entendu des
propos
un peu tourner différence est un peu
contradictoire
des manières
vaurien certain nombre de choses que je
voulais dire que c'est déjà dit donc se
voir répéter comme le ton est assez
limité
je vais revenir sur certains points pour
que ce soit plus clair
c'est vrai il ya la vienne s'en faut
savoir simple étirement des ces pays
développés
c'est un pays que les pannes et les
populations se parlent est aujourd'hui
ce sont des populations qui vivent des
milliers 2010 année
elles ont vécu ensemble ils ont deux
cultures de mode de vie ancestral
dépassé comme toutes les deux pays
comptent toutes les populations elles
ont vécu des périodes différé des
différents elles ont vécu les 21e siècle
avancés avec tout le monde
en tant que pierre weill détient
toujours
qu'il y avait dans le passé des périodes
de très glorieux très avancé des
personnalités des savons des
connaissances des cultures assez avancé
bon avant qu'un ancien club surtout les
données partie du 20e siècle
la raison elle devient la carrefour des
affrontements des intérêts des
différents un domaine de différents
payer
qu'elle soit au niveau international qui
sont au niveau
régionales
démarrant dépérit les périodes où il y
avait
le bloc est ce opposé à gombe à l'ouest
c'est à dire les dix années de guerre
les soviétiques contre les j'appelle pas
construire les poppers 20 mai contre
l'occident mais c'est par avion
interposés c'est nous et était imposé
parfois de la après auarit fin de
deuxième période ce sont la guerre
interne de puissance régionale c'est à
dire entre la réalité viron le pakistan
que vous allez l'entendre a ensuite je
suis encore par un wagon interposée ou
on appelle les gars il apprend qui est
en réalité
tout argent toutes les munitions tous
ses moyens de guerre étaient donnés par
les puissances régionales
passées de cette période arrivée des
talibans
l'arrivée des talibans parce c'était la
caisse de talibans c'était trop pays
c'était là l'arabie saoudite quand
l'iran le pakistan qui est trouvée
voulait avoir subi sur notre liaison à
sans discussion une fois que l'union
soviétique avait perdu la guerre longue
et sans donc de s'accaparer c'est un bon
moment et les états unis qui donnait le
feu vert donc ces trois pays ont créé le
talent pour la première fois en
donc elles ont arrivés petit à petit en
1996 qu'ils ont dominique kaboul qu'ils
ont pris kaboul en main mais il y avait
le gouvernement avant de l'époque mais
sera bientôt en prison et que mon âme
ensuite comme le chef
militaire
des résistants qui a duré pendant
plusieurs années normalement le projet
des talibans c'était pour un
qui devait
écarter toutes les tous ceux qui
aspirent à la liberté de préparer le
terrain pour que leurs ouailles revient
mais malheureusement ça tient plus en
temps quelqu'un de sincère mais
finalement ça devient gênant il fallut
le dealer
après nous sommes nous arrivés à
périodes où c'est
la chute de telles bombes d'huile 2000
2001 on a essayé d des bars et des
talibans en 2001 il veut le 11 septembre
seraient
939 ce temps qui est à maturation le
chef
de résistants afghans étaient assassinés
donc nous
arrivant un nouvelle période de
l'afghanistan
maintenant je m'arrête à cette période
cette vingtaine d'années qui nous ont
vécu j'ai entendu des propos de monsieur
notre ami monsieur par exemple et
d'autres gens ont parlé des cultures des
avions d'époque et les femmes et aime
maîtriser qu'ils n'avaient pas de
culture qui j'ai fait le droit et qui
était vraiment
c'était les pressions de deuxième
catégorie qui était quelque part
carrément maîtrisé je suis à 63 ans j'ai
vu qu'il est temps de roide première
république la deuxième la troisième la
quatrième et cinquième maintenant les
talibans la deuxième fois
je peux vous dire qu'elle les allemands
comme les français comme n'importe qui
d'autre les adorent leur fille ils
adorent leur femme ils adorent leur mère
elsa dorlin lanceur elles sont prêtes à
mourir pour ces gens airs sans compter
les femmes aiment le rock on leur ferme
leurs maris leurs pères leurs mains
il y avait qu est-ce qu il était
le fait de manque des moyens
d'éloignement
le manque de culture pendant tout le
xxème siècle l'école était
pratiquement inexistant à un garçon ça
c'était une volonté politique les pays
voisins pas qu'ils sont à l'erreur à
français mais chez nous il n'y avait pas
d'école parce que c'était une volonté
politique on ne voulait pas développé de
l'étape et l'école
et les période communiste arrivé en
langage on aura ouvert la porte des
cornes à tout le monde donc
pour dire un peu
donc cette méprise
n'existait pas à l'encontre des femmes
qu'on ne maîtrise pas excusez mon mari
est ce que parce que oui comme une femme
en a on avoue pouvez essayer de nous
parler de votre action vous êtes au sein
de ce que
on a déjà parlé de la situation en
afghanistan met de votre action concrète
s'il vous plaît notre monde actions
concernent
pour dire que le talent immense ce n'est
pas vraiment ce qu'ils y font ce n'est
pas la culture ni de nom ni de se
délester de nulle part de l'argent la
musique elle est appréciée par tout le
monde la liberté de la famille au sein
de la famille et il est toujours dans
toute une histoire est respectée
aujourd'hui
de manière dans la rue mois sacré les
femmes et les gens ça n'a jamais existé
donc ce qu'il faut le talent est bon ça
ne relève pas de la culture nées de la
tradition de ce pays les religieux la
religion n'est de leur culture
ancestrale
donc pour nous faire savoir de cette
manière vous le fait que j'ai entendu
certains nombre de journalistes
maintenant qu'ils nous allons en gazon
et la pelouse de sécurité nous
traversons avec beaucoup de sécurité les
halles endroit à l'autre c'est vrai
chouchoute
les journalistes les diplomates ou des
étrangers
aujourd'hui pour leur reconnaissance
internationale
mais qu'ils aient la vie des populations
sur place
elle vit la cochère vie la terreur vie
tous les jours
l'ema cercle de
voile à toutes ses faces son travail
toutes saisons son travail tout les
militaires tout les policiers son
travail se cache comme des souris donc
c'est ça la réalité de talibans
d'aujourd'hui ce qu'elle fait exercer
est ce qu on entend par certains noms
d'un
un
certain nombre de personnalités et il
faut s'arranger avec les talibans on n'a
pas d'autre choix on peut pas faire
autrement s'il vous plaît non on
s'arrange pas coûté de calibre c'est
terrible aujourd'hui sur que villa les
femmes à la maison c'est terrible et si
on la reconnaît ceci va être perpétué la
reconnaissance d'un talent immense de
dire que nous reconnaissons à jamais les
droits des femmes les droits de parole
le droit de la liberté le droit à la
parole au congrès
20 dernières années on a vu comment
cette nation est capable d'avancer alors
elles ont cette capacité d'avancer
si on reconnaît les talibans se dit on
reconnaît qui est ce jeune n'a pas le
droit d'avancer de danser comme ça mais
qui sont forme de l'enfer
donc dans ce qu'elle ne se soit pas
qu'elle est bien souvent nos rentrées
comme dit notre ami ce sera un centre
protégé pour toutes les sortes de
tourisme ils vont partir partout ils ont
envie d'aller donc
maintenant il ya deux choses d'un côté
le téléphone que je milite pour nourrir
son salut bon donc j'ai des actions en
les commandant et je vais amener des
actions bien ciblées
la deuxième maintenant cette famine
cette situation difficile comment faire
moi je pense à mon avis on a des
structures internationaux il est nations
unies il ya toutes les origines dans
l'arsenal
c'est leur devoir de apporter de l'aide
et
pour les pauvres et sans danger n'ont
pas donné qu'on demande à notre ami seth
l'argent gelé dans les mains des
talibans elles vont et tous les efforts
eux mêmes contre la population alors il
ne faut surtout pas ça et les aime et
veut pas car finalement tellement il
faut qu'ils aient acheminée auprès des
populations
cela de voir
des nations unies et des pays
responsables de la sécurité mondiale
donc je pense que c'est ça qui est
important
pour le mot de fin donc moi je pense que
c'est bien de sauver les femmes et les
hommes qui sont en danger en a 15 ans
mais ces 27 38 minutes de gens qui
habitent à l'intérieur de la vienne sont
donc je demande solennellement de l'est
de la france des gouvernements français
et des responsables je suis dans un
centre structures d'aidé de la france je
demande solennellement de chercher des
solutions pour l'afghanistan et l'europe
doit intervenir états unis nations unies
la russie et la chine qui ont eu
aujourd'hui ils caressent le dos des
talibans trouvez vous les a amenés
sainement menace c'est terrible vous
nous enterrer avec mes tableaux mais
chercher les solutions sortie nous c'est
peut-être à sortir de cette difficulté
il faut que nous ne voulons pas
commandé avant ces
fabuleux simplement avoir droit de vivre
et vivre dignement merci
merci infiniment madame pour votre
témoignage et pour tout ce que vous avez
fait depuis 25 ans en afghanistan et il
te vai et on a bien en effet compris
que vous aviez besoin de soutien soutien
de deux de nos pays merci infiniment
pour vos témoignages je passe maintenant
la parole à marie george buffet que je
salue
la députée merci beaucoup d'abord je
voudrais
relayer ce que vient de dire schouppe
rien
il y a un potentiel de résistance
important en afghanistan
parce que ces femmes afghanes ont connu
d'autres périodes où elles ont été
reconnues comme des individus à part
entière avec des droits à l'éducation au
travail ce sont donc ces femmes pour
certaines sont en résistance là
aujourd'hui en ce moment
et moi je veux une fois encore salué le
courage inouï de celles qui sont sortis
dans la rue là bas à kaboul et dans
d'autres villes
donc
il ya besoin du soutien international
mais en faisant confiance au peuple
afghan aux démocrates afghans et parmi
eux aux femmes afghanes
pour mener ce combat pour les libertés
et les droits
et je te soutiens ce cas 10 août ria ce
n'est pas une affaire de culture afghane
voilà où ne peut en aucun cas justifier
les décisions prises par ceux de régime
autoritaire arrivé par la violence à
l'encontre des femmes c'est la première
chose toujours est dire la deuxième
chose c'est
ça a été déjà dit mais il faut sauver
les médias on sait bien comment savent
sa vie vous avez un événement vous le
traitez pendant 15 jours puis vous
passez à autre chose
il ne faut pas qu'on passe à autre chose
ils font qu'on mène une mobilisation en
france et dans d'autres pays qui font
tout l'afghanistan reste une question
d'actualité et où le sang des femmes en
afghanistan reste une question
d'actualité
j'ai encore posé une question
d'actualité hier à l'assemblée nationale
sur ces discussions question pour faire
en sorte que le gouvernement se sentant
responsabilité sur la durée par rapport
à ce qui se passe en afghanistan
alors troisième chose sous trial l'a dit
mais
moi j'ai été très choqué quand j'ai vu
les premières photos quelques jours
après l'arrivée du pouvoir des talibans
au pouvoir de grands responsables
chinois posé à côté de ces responsables
afghans dans un souci bien sûr
économiques ou géopolitiques etc
nous n'avons pas à négocier avec les
talibans
nous avons un combat de ce régime avec
les démocrates et les femmes afghanes
alors comment poser comment agir d'abord
je voudrais vous remercier
mesdames les sénatrices d'avoir organisé
cette initiative nous allons tenir des
initiatives aussi à l'assemblée
nationale notamment un colloque le 13
décembre
et moi les échos me remonte beaucoup
d'initiatives se prennent sur le terrain
dès demain il ya plusieurs débats en
seine saint denis dans le 77 qu'un
comité départemental qui se met en place
fin on sent que le pleine mobilisation
qui se met en place aux côtés des femmes
afghanes
alors je vais prendre un exemple
de comment on peut faire pression
nous avons les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
en 2024
en 2000 j'avais déjà créé un comité de
soutien aux femmes afghanes avec de
nombreuses sportif sportive pardon
actrice élus et on a vu pour mot d'ordre
de dire nous voulons des femmes afghanes
aux jeux olympiques d'athènes 2004
nous voulons payer des femmes qu'ils
puissent pratiquer le sport qu'ils
soient dans les guerres dans les
délégations afghane aux jeux olympiques
d'athènes 2004
nous n'avons pas réussi sur les jeux
olympiques nous avons réussi sur la
coupe du monde d'athlétisme où deux
jeunes afghanes ont pu participer et
nous avons réussi à organiser un match
de balle de volée à kaboul
auquel j'ai assisté
mythe avec des garçons et des filles qui
ont joué ensemble au volley
le sport c'est le port
donc pratiquer le sport pour un homme
pour une femme se saisir de son corps
pour se dépasser pour se faire du bien
pour s'épanouir pour concourir etc c'est
une des libertés c'est comme l'adsea
culture or une des premières décisions
des talibans et de diamants femmes le
sport c'est terminé et puis vous pouvez
pu les voir à la télévision et puis on
veut pas et donc prenons le contre-pied
nous voulons que les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de paris 2024 n'accepte
que des délégations qui soit miz
que délégation qui soit mythe j'ai écrit
en ce sens au cio comité international
olympique otomi t national olympique et
sportif français à la ministre des
sports au responsable du cojo il faut
mener cette bataille on ne peut pas
de façon honteuse fermer les yeux
sous un prétexte de politiquement
correct avec le cio ou je ne sais quoi
accepter ce qu'on a vu dans d'autres
jeux olympiques des délégations ou
parfois on mettait quelques femmes à
l'arrière sans mettre à l'arrière pour
surtout ne voyais pas trop tout en
interdisant la pratique dans leur propre
pays l'accès à la pratique sportive donc
voila moi j'ai pris ce créneau je vais
pas le lâcher
parce que on va parler de plus en plus
des gp 2024 ça commence les pubs les
spots publicitaires etc etc il faut
qu'on ait cette exigence d'abord c'est
conforme à la charte olympique
alors je sais que le cio
est très beau mentir et léger lorsqu'il
s'agit de négocier les grands événements
sportifs on ne voit avec la coupe du
monde au qatar
mais là je pense qu'il faut vraiment
qu'on ait cette démarche quand j'ai vu
ces femmes juges
passer devant le responsable de la coupe
du monde du qatar et alors que les
autres arbitres hommes avaient eu du
lait craignent les contrôles serment
demain etc il y eut deux femmes juges
ont dû passer au se tenant bien droites
et surtout non en ne tentant pas la main
etc je ne veux pas que ça se reproduise
ou géo paix de paris 2024 donc voilà
c'est la proposition que je fais allez
bien sûr très on va mener tous les
combats nécessaires et de toutes les
initiatives mais moi je veux je veux
travailler ce créneau là parce que ça
peut être un créneau qui mobilise
beaucoup l'opinion voilà c'est juste ce
que je voulais vous dire et je vous
invite bien sûr au colloque à
l'assemblée le 13 décembre merci madame
la députée et
je pense quand j'ai vu dans la salle mes
collègues ont relaiera en effet votre
votre votre combat sur les docks je
pense que c'est en effet formidable et
comme vous l'avez dit vous avez fait une
question hier c'était vraiment
instinctif de notre part à tous parce
qu'il ya aussi quelques collègues hommes
je salue
mon ami ici présent jeu
je pense qu'on était tous d'accord pour
dire que en cette journée du 25 novembre
bien évidemment on pense en général à
toutes les femmes victimes de violences
mais comme vous dites il ne faut pas les
faut pas oublier d afghanistan et que
heureusement madame boudoul et ya des
journalistes qui encore sur place
continuent à montrer la façon dont la
situation se dégrade c'est vrai qu'on a
toujours un coup de projecteur sur des
événements phares et puis après on
oublie ce qui se passe là-bas et est
effrayant et je pense que vraiment c'est
important dans cette journée on puisse
le dire je vais céder la parole
maintenant notre dernier intervenant
david martinon donc ambassadeur de
france en afghanistan et
va vous revenir l'honneur de clôturer
cette dernière séquence merci vraiment
d'être parmi nous monsieur l'ambassadeur
et je vous cède la parole
merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la ministre merci de m'avoir
invité aujourd'hui et me laisser le
l'honneur et le privilège et la lourde
responsabilité de conclure je voudrais
d'abord dire que je me sont extrêmement
en phase avec ce qu'on dit mesdames et
d' arrêt buffet
et je vais et je vais y revenir je
voudrais peut-être dire deux choses
d'abord revenir deux secondes sur le
constat même s'il est assez largement et
ensuite répondre à la question que vous
me posez madame la sénatrice sur ce que
l'on peut faire ce que l'on devrait
faire sur le constat que je vais aller
vite les talibans n'ont pas changé sur
la question des femmes en général et en
particulier sur la question des femmes
tout ce que l'on a vu est extrêmement
sombre
peut-être qu'on ce peut-être que vous en
avait déjà parlé mais on avait été
frappée eiffage avait été partiellement
frappe est d'entendre ce
ce clair
bien peu sophistiquée expliquant la
télévision il ya maintenant deux mois et
demi que les femmes ne devait plus
porter de vêtements
chatoyant ne devait plus c'est pas être
parfumée s'est elle ne devait plus
sentir bon et elle ne devait pas porter
de chaussures à talons parce que le
bruit des talons sur le sol est un appel
aux hommes au jeune homme donc comme si
c'était la faute des jeunes hommes des
femmes le désir des hommes et la faute
des femmes
tout ce que l'on voit
dans la réaction des journalistes
doit être
pardon je m'exprime mal j'ai vu des
réactions de journalistes étrangers à
kaboul dire non mais les talibans sont
cordiaux et oui bien sûr les sont
cordiaux avec les journalistes étrangers
elle n'y a pas de doute mais nous savons
que les exécutions sommaires sont
quotidiennes je reçois tous les jours
des vidéos des images d'exécutions
sommaires
et en effet les informations qu'on a
c'est que les femmes ne sont pas
épargnées
donc tous les progrès de ces dernières
années sont en effet complètement remis
en cause et c'est triste parce que l'art
est le bilan de la république islamique
d'afghanistan
n'est pas flamboyant mais enfin la place
des femmes le dynamisme de la société
civile dynamisme de la presse qui était
la plus libre et la plus professionnelle
de toute la grande région centre
asiatique tout ça est remis en question
je suis très touché de voir madame la
ministre mende avec nous aujourd'hui
puisque nous vous avions invité en 2000
en 2019 et je sais que pour les femmes
qui étaient qui s'était engagé
évidemment c'est beaucoup plus difficile
maintenant alors pour ce qui est du
constat donc les talibans n'ont pas
changé nous le savions nous l'avions dit
tout le monde ne le croyais pas
maintenant alors maintenant il ya quand
même beaucoup de nos partenaires qui
pense quand même qu'ils ont changé et
voilà qu'il ya quand même une difficulté
à voir la réalité en face et je voudrais
aussi souligner ce cas de madame médard
même si vous connaissez la culture
afghane bien mieux que moi c'est que ce
que représentent les talibans ça n'est
pas l'afghanistan ça n'est pas
l'afghanistan la musique à kandahar
c'est une tradition multiséculaire
et voit la boxe est un islam radical
qui qui qui n'est pas en phase avec tout
ce qui se passe avec toute la culture
afghane
pour ce qui est de la situation
humanitaire
oui elle est mauvaise
mais elle est mauvaise il n'y a pas de
doute mais je
jeudi enfin j'appelle à prendre un peu
de distance avec un certain nombre
d'appels
qui vise à culpabiliser la communauté
internationale il faut pas exagérer les
choses la situation est mauvaise mais
voyez quand j'ai posé la question à la
représentante d'onu femmes sur le cobp
id elle a répondu à côté c'est à dire
que peut-être qu'il va y avoir une
quatrième vague de covile mais
aujourd'hui a pas de vide sur les 3000
personnes qu'on a évacué en août il ya
eu ils ont tous été testés à l'arrivée
il ya eu zéro cas positifs
donc il faut pas non plus raconté
n'importe quoi je ne dis pas qu'il n'y
aura pas une quatrième vague mais je dis
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas donc il faut
pas raconter des n'a pas n'importe quoi
juste pour dire qu'il faut donner plus
d'argent et j'y viens parce que en
l'occurrence
la france et la communauté
internationale sont extrêmement
généreuse avec l'afghanistan aujourd'hui
dire que quand la france a annoncé 100
millions d'euros d'aidé humanitaire
fin août je peux vous dire que j'étais
content mais j'ai aussi en tête ce que
j'obtenais les années d'avant c'est à
dire que en 2019 moi j'avais trois cent
mille euros d aide alimentaire d'urgence
en 2020 j'ai eu un million d'euros parce
qu'il y avait une aide budgétaire
au
co vide pour pour rétablir les comptes
de l'institut médical français de la
mère et de l'enfant
donc il faut surtout pas douter de
l'extrême générosité encore une fois de
la france et de la communauté
internationale
je ne connais pas d'autres pays pour la
pour lequel on donne 100 millions
d'euros d'aidé humanitaire en ce moment
c'est c'est très important et puis
ensuite il est important de comprendre
quelle est cette situation humanitaire
quelles sont les causes
on nous dit il ya énormément de déplacés
oui mais ça c'est en effet on les a vus
on les a vus depuis deux ans trois ans
parce que au fur et à mesure de la
reconquête par les talibans les gens
fuyaient la guerre les gens fuyaient les
combats donc ils ont fui les combats à
l'automne dernier dernier quand quand la
guerre faisait rage de autour de deux
camps d'art ils sont venus près de
kaboul et à mais c'est pas un phénomène
des deux derniers mois des trois
derniers c'est pas vrai ça il faut pas
il faut pas tronquer la réalité par
ailleurs si ce sont de déplacés internes
ça arrive de façon assez saisonnière
aussi en afghanistan le pays est
désormais il n'y a plus de guerre dans
le pays donc ils peuvent très bien
repartir chez eux je dis pas que c'est
facile mais je dis qu'il faut avoir une
vision claire de la situation
troisièmement la sécheresse oui moi j'ai
passé trois ans en afghanistan j'ai
connu trois sécheresse donc là on est en
fin de ces chiffres s il ya déjà des
chutes de neige donc c'est aussi un
épisode qui va passer donc c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut pas faire les choses
mais il faut essayer d'avoir une vision
précise la pardonnez moi juste deux ans
parce qu'en fait mamoudou nous a fait
enfin rien fait un reportage sur tf1
disons que c'était pas pour que la bise
et du tout ni la france ni non
simplement parce qu'aujourd'hui les
talibans empêchent beaucoup de gens de
travailler et que même les
fonctionnaires ne sont plus payés depuis
plusieurs mois les gens n'ont plus rien
pour pouvoir acheter leurs vivres c'est
vraiment ça qui a été montré et que en
fait j'ai à dire vraiment là la
dénutrition de certaines catégories
voire jusqu'aux classes moyennes dans
les prochaines semaines risquent de
s'aggraver à cause de ça c'est c'est eh
c'est quand même ça qui est paraît-il
alarmant dans dans les semaines qui
viennent en fait voilà c'est plus que le
coc vie dont nous en effet ou
ou le fait qu' on ne fasse rien c'est à
l'intérieur du pays enfin c'est fois
qu'on vous remontre le reportage mais
c'est surtout ça en fait ouais non mais
je partage ce constat
je partage je partage totalement ce
constat il s'était pas du tout aux
journalistes que je pensais que sur ce
camp je décrivais c'était fort pour pour
culpabiliser la communauté
internationale je voyais alors je
déroule que faire maintenant
alors donc l'aide humanitaire 100
millions d'euros pour ce qui est de la
france nous allons nous appuyer
essentiellement sur les agences
onusiennes parce qu'elles sont encore
présentes dans le pays et que pour nous
la priorité des priorités c'est en effet
de venir en aide aux réfugiés et aux
déplacés donc essentiellement nous
allons
apporter de l'aide c'est que c'est déjà
fait recette décaissé ces faits au
commissariat des nations unies pour les
réfugiés qui est présente en afghanistan
et qui est aussi présent sur les pays du
voisinage
ensuite ça c'est plus urgents ensuite
notre priorité c'est bien sûr les femmes
et des enfants et c'est là où il faut
être déjà il faut aussi plus fin parce
qu'en réalité
nous ce que nous voulons c'est être
efficace immédiatement directement donc
comme vous le savez probablement la
france soutient et opère depuis
2006 de l'institut médical français de
la mère et de l'enfant à kaboul
dès que les conditions c'est de sécurité
seront réunies on va se poser évidemment
la question de savoir si la voie de la
chaîne de l'espoir peut reprendre ses
missions à kaboul
jeudi qu'aucune décision n'a été prise
parce qu'encore une fois il faut essayer
de contrôler un certain nombre de choses
mais
c'est sûr que c'est un très bon projet
d'abord parce que on aime bien creuser
notre sillon c'est un hôpital de
remarquables et
on sait qu'il ya 200 enfants qui vont
mourir s'ils ne sont pas opérées donc là
c'est sûr que c'est une manière d'aider
directement les femmes et les enfants
pour le reste moi j'attends des projets
de la part de l'onu femmes on a prévu
une enveloppe pour une femme n'hésite
pas encore entendu de projets
ensuite
l'aide humanitaire oui et la france l'a
dit le premier président de la
république l'a dit répété le ministre
affaires étrangères également mais
l'aide donc l'aide humanitaire est
inconditionnel maintenant et je reprends
ce qu'on dit madame edda mellas buffet
le g7 le conseil de l'union européenne
dès août ont fixé des conditions à la
reprise du travail avec les autorités de
fait en afghanistan parmi ces conditions
il y a notamment le respect des droits
de l'homme et donc des droits des femmes
et donc des droits des femmes
je j'insiste il est indispensable d'être
stricte là dessus si on est pas et un
certain nombre de partenaires
donnent l'impression d'être déjà en
train de négocier avec eux mêmes pour
nous
donc j'ai compris qu'on était filmé et
donc je je vais juste rester dans le
vague un certain nombre de nos
partenaires sont déjà en train de
négocier avec eux mêmes pour en fait ne
pas respecter les conditions qu'ils ont
eux mêmes fixé pour pouvoir faire
beaucoup plus que de l'humanitaire mais
si c'est ça alors on rend les clés aux
talibans et c'est ce que nous ne voulons
pas je voudrais les un tout petit peu
plus loin je pense que la communauté
internationale a probablement été
maladroite oui elle peut peut-être
trompé deux sujets parfois elle s'est
trompée de priorité mais on ne peut pas
lui dénier le fait qu'elle a été
incroyablement généreuse avec
l'afghanistan depuis
j'allais dire depuis 2001 puisque ils
s'affairent selon les critères on peut
dire qu'il ya eu entre 4 et 8 plan
marshall pour un pays
mais on peut aussi revenir avant 2001
même entre 96 et 2001 plutôt 98 2001 du
temps du premier amour à talais ben la
communauté internationale a été
généreuse avec l'afghanistan
au sens où
constatant que le régime était
incompétent pour délivrer les services
publics de base à la population afghane
la communauté internationale à financer
les agences de l'onu et un certain
nombre d ong pour en réalité faire ce
travail à kaboul et ailleurs et donc
on est venu en aide à la population mais
on a aussi renforcé le régime des
talibans on l'est on leur a permis de ne
pas être redevable de leur incapacité à
faire leur travail de gouvernants et ce
faisant on leur a permis de se
concentrer sur leur passe temps favori
qu'ils sont et je crains qu'il ne le
soit de mecs qui ne se répètent qu'ils
sont la chasse aux opposants politiques
et l'oppression des femmes qui sont la
collecte des dollars d'une région pas
très lointaine et les affaires
religieuses je voudrais surtout qu'à un
moment on s'arrête et on se dise ok ça
n'a pas marché réfléchissons à comment
il faudrait ajuster notre notre aide et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
à la fois évidemment une question
éthique et mais c'est aussi une question
d'efficacité comment les talibans
peuvent ils imaginer qu'ils vont réussir
le développement de leur pays en se
privant de 50% de la force de travail du
pays ça n'a aucun sens s'il n'y a pas un
pays qui se développe dans ces
conditions troisièmement
nous continuons les évacuations
et je ne pourrai pas en dire beaucoup
plus parce que nous le faisons dans des
conditions qui sont de plus en plus
difficile
parce qu'encore une fois nous ne sommes
plus à kaboul pour des raisons de
sécurité des raisons politiques puisque
retourner à kaboul ça veut dire quoi
qu'en disent les uns et les autres ça
veut dire quand même reconnaître le
régime de fait et donc nous ne tenons
pas
nous avons
il va qu ait beaucoup de femmes en
réalité depuis ces derniers mois avant
le but tu as lu pendant qu est-ce que
vous avez eue c'est vrai que vous aimez
nous avons évacué tous nos
collaborateurs afghan de l'ambassade de
l'institut français la délégation
archéologique et donc les hommes et les
femmes les femmes et leurs conjoints et
les enfants
nous avons pendant les 15 derniers jours
d'août sortie encore beaucoup de femmes
notamment moi je vais mis l'accent sur
les artistes donc nous avons sorti un
certain nombre de cinéastes femmes nous
avons sorti un certain nombre d'artistes
plastique femmes nous avons sorti un
certain nombre de journalistes et
d'activistes des droits de l'homme
madame la ministre il a le plaisir nous
avons eu plaisir d'évacuer des athlètes
paralympiques au mois d'août notamment
cette femme athlètes
karatéka
qui a pu rejoindre tokyo juste après
jeu j'adore votre proposition je vais si
vous permettez la ferme yens autant que
possible parce que je la trouve de bon
sens
non seulement bon sens mais en plus
efficace et l'air ça va les forcer à
réagir j'ajoute que en effet c'est
plutôt dans le constat mais
pour ce qui est des femmes sportives en
ce moment c'est très difficile
l'entraîneur d'une équipe féminine de
volleyball a été assassiné à et rate un
jeune un jeune père de famille ça tout
ça tout ça est déplorable
donc nous continuons les évacuations
mais je ne veux pas créer de faux
espoirs je reçois tous les jours entre
100 et 150 demandes nous ne pourrons pas
y faire droit
et ça devient de plus en plus difficile
mais j'ai des femmes en tête qui sont
particulièrement en danger sur lesquels
nous travaillons en ce moment et donc je
n'en dirai pas plus et puis il nous faut
soutenir les femmes qui prennent la
parole donc ça c'est quelque chose que
sur lequel nous allons travailler mais
il est très important que les femmes
alors évidemment moi je suis très
réticent à
enfin je ne veux surtout pas qu'on mette
en danger les femmes en afghanistan qui
prennent la parole parce que vraiment
elles risquent gros mais toutes celles
qui ont pu sortir il faut qu'on mette en
place
un soutien pour qu'elle puisse prendre
la parole et qu'elle puisse garder la la
lumière la lumière allumée
merci beaucoup monsieur ambassadeur est
en effet sur vos derniers propos une
intervenante de la première table ronde
nous disait qu en effet
quatre droits de l'hommistes femmes
avaient été assassinées en tout cas
c'était celle dont on avait eu
connaissance et que bien évidemment le
craignais qu'on ait beaucoup d'autres et
donc comme vous dites prendre la parole
ou vous faire de la politique quand on
est femme dans ces pays c'est c'est
double peine
dire une chose parce que ce que j'ai dit
sur la situation humanitaire est
peut-être paru peut-être à part un peu
brutal mais si je dis ça c'est parce que
je veux pas qu'on
pendant pendant vingt ans on a noyé ce
pays sous les fonds et on en a fait une
économie de rente et comme toutes les
économies de rente à part la norvège ça
marche pas je voudrais absolument éviter
que par des appels à des dons
illimitées ont recréé une économie de
rente et on aide les taliban et on
recrée de la corruption voilà c'est pour
ça que seaspan là dessus on m'a dit que
c'était très intéressant dans les mêmes
ce que vous avez dit sur le sur le fait
qu'on finalement on les laisser faire
leur
leur activité préférée en finalement
suppléant alors alors des organisations
administratives et politiques etc j'ai
trouvé ça très intéressant madame la
présidente je vous laisse la parole peut
être pour qu'on puisse avoir un temps
des changes avec vous avez encore
quelques minutes très bien merci
monsieur l'ambassadeur merci à vous
mesdames pour cette table ronde on va
peut-être rester dans cette
configuration va pas perdre de temps
comme ça pour le jeu des questions
réponses et donc vous madame vous
souhaitiez intervenir tout à l'heure
vous souhaitez toujours
donc traduction s'il vous plaît
et merci de vous représenter puisque il
ya des gens qui ont rejoint la
conférence entre-temps
tâche à
commercy madame la présidente de m'avoir
donné le temps je suis jeune et salim
est avocate en ancien fonctionnaire de
programme de l'onu pour le développement
je demande les questions à madame alice
jeune ayew ne vaut même je crois qu'elle
n'est pas à brancher je veux bien envoyé
ma question
[Musique]
je suis sortie de l'afghanistan au nago
nietzsche et je suis arrivé en france à
19 août ce que je vois actuellement
c'est ce que quand je parle avec ma
famille en afghanistan ont pris à les
médias je le vois j'ai entendu ces
propos je crois qu'il faut entrer
directement en contact avec les femmes
afghanes pour pouvoir nous occuper de
leurs besoins ce qui me semble en tant
que fille afghane est tout à fait opposé
à
[Musique]
ce qu'on va faire en analystes la fidl
et les chefs de l'human à adder re la
sade et
réunion perpétuel avec les talibans mais
il n'y a pas une seule session réunion
avec les femmes en quoi il n'a ni le
chef de yuma des humains peut-être que
il ya des réunions
secrètes confidentielles
si c'est confidentiel
et qu'il
est à l'un des articles de chartes des
droits de l'homme était la liberté
d'expression si la liberté d'expression
les pères et exécuté ces n'est pas
respectée c'est violation de la charte
des droits de l'homme et cela renforce
les talibans parce que les unes ammann a
peur de cette coque alors une fédé de ce
petit réunions secrètes confidentielles
en plus du quart des regards des
talibans alors je demande un alice ion
et la société des aunisiennes en
abaissant pourquoi
vous nous préparons direct contact avec
les femmes afghanes qui sont sur la sur
terrain pourquoi on va pas avec elle
directement et si on parle directement
on voit que ça sur le site
internet et pourquoi je n'ai pas
répercutée dans les médias
je prends du test deuxième question
je vais parler du moule et des propos de
monsieur l'ambassadeur
nous ne devons pas
et
sacrifier les aides humanitaires
aux affaires politiques ce que j'avais
dix mois les aides humanitaires
être fondée sur cinq principes là de ses
trains c'est l'indépendance
c'est z
de l'union européenne ou n'importe quel
pays
du monde n'est pas c'est un indépendant
ce indépendamment ça n'aboutira à rien
on va nourrir on va donner plus de
pouvoir aux gouverneurs que la gueule
l'afghan ne veut pas merci madame zeyneb
salem en réalité votre intervention fait
écho à ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
puisque
ça a été dit par plusieurs intervenants
de la table ronde les talibans ne
peuvent être en aucun cas les
interlocuteurs nous ne pouvons pas avoir
confiance dans les talibans donc oui à
partir du moment où il doit y avoir des
contacts avec onu femmes par exemple les
contacts de se mener en direct la
confiance n'existe pas avec les talibans
le deuxième sujet que vous avez évoqué
c'était led led qui vient qui arrive en
afghanistan monsieur l'ambassadeur il
est fait référence et madame
dhalla boudoul également tout à l'heure
dans ses propos l'aide elle doit être
inconditionnel inconditionnel messi et
de l'aide est inconditionnelle elle doit
elle doit également ne pas passer par
les talibans c'est à dire que pour
qu'elles arrivent au bon endroit l'aide
elle doit être gérée différemment avec
notamment les instances onusiennes et ça
a été dit tout à l'heure oui une
wii allez-y monsieur
merci
ma question s'adresse
mais c'est matignon mais ces
ambassadeurs que malheureusement je ne
connais pas personnellement quand
remonte à tous les ambassadeurs
de france depuis 2001
on est conscient que la france
ni aujourd'hui ni dans le passé n'a pas
de grandes interviews politiques
par rapport aux états unis à la chine à
la russie environ six heures
cependant la france c'est un pays
qui a été très très présente en un en
avant le sens donc plusieurs domaines
l'éducation notamment je crois que
l'istiqlal et là des plus anciennes
lycée et français dans le monde
dans les domaines d'habiles rupture dans
le domaine de l'archéologie dans enfin
et surtout dans
popopopop pour former
une par une grande partie de l'élite
de l'état de passer du rire avant avant
ces quarante dernières années
bon ah non quant aux envois par rapport
à 7
se passer à cette histoire la france a
besoin en fait je crois que dans deux
ans
dans d'autres on va célébrer
l'anniversaire de santi a mené de
l'établissement des relations
diplomatiques entre la france est et la
renaissance je ne pense pas que
l'engagement de la france aujourd'hui
même hier même ir loscos dans le cadre
de la la lutte ou entre guillemets la
guerre contre le terrorisme mais surtout
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
permettez-moi de remarquer que la
situation est beaucoup plus grave que
vous pensez le dernier rapport du
pam long alimentaire mondial grasset 9
milliards on
classe parmi la catégorie 4 il y a un
deux trois quatre cinq catégories la
catégorie
de catégorie 5 c'est la mort
donc 9000 une table ronde et se trouve
actuellement dans le 4 4 et 4 donc
sonades évidemment que la comédie
atteindre 100 étaient toujours présentes
en adressant au nom faux pas ni son rôle
et sa place mais aujourd'hui avoue le
sang se trouve dans une soie sont
extrêmement vraiment extrêmement grave
je vous donne un exemple par rapport aux
excellents le reportage qu'on a vu dans
lequel on entendait qu une petite fille
est vendu 500 dollars il y a quatre cinq
mois avant même la prise de temps les
bandes le prix était de 2000 $
je viens de voir une vidéo émouvante
que vous pouvez consulter dans ses
réseaux sociaux et sur youtube un homme
est interviewé avec ses petites enfants
ils proposent ils proposent
une de chaque fille à 4000 as gagné vous
savez savez combien
39 euros
imaginez le prix d'une petite fille
39 euros pour qu'ils puissent vers
nourrir le reste de la famille donc 100
millions $ ou 100 millions aux
responsables représente vous savez
l'allemagne comme a consacré comme bien
600 millions d'euros
bah absolument qu'ils absalon et à doha
entre ankara a fait adopter 600 millions
de dépôts monétaires jambes en avançant
vous savez le pays bas le petit pays de
pays bas qu'est ce qu'il fait il prendre
en charge il prend en charge le salaire
des instituteurs avec d'étalement heures
en même temps bon au delà de la question
humanitaire puisque mon domaine comme
tout à l'heure vous étiez pas là cela je
vous dis qu'ils écoutent
excusez moi parce que est ce que c'est
la question c'est prendre la question
mais au-delà de cette situation
humanitaire au delà du fait qu'il faut
je suis d'accord il faut faire parvenir
l'aide
indépendamment de leur demande ou de
hemmar ats d'amis mais outre sa mais la
france quand même et pour jouer un rôle
politique aujourd'hui je ne vois pas la
france est absent de chaque initiative
qui a été heureux autour de la brousse
temps là la france était absente en
france de moto le terran de sam hamad de
deux derniers délits excel extra et ex
terrain et je vois la question à poser
est
quel projet vous avez en fer politique
et par rapport à cette situation
je vous remercie on s'écoute compris la
caution vous allez continuer à 10,15 on
est entre de bonnes mains
merci merci beaucoup on a compris la
question je peux pas vous laisser dire
midi un ami tu n'as besoin d'hommes qui
sont obligés de faire danser carennac
avait
été moi même pendant l'été sollicité par
d'aider des personnes afghanes de femmes
notamment et qui souhaitait quitter je
dois dire que
les affaires étrangères et des services
ont été d'une grande réactivité
donc on peut pas dire et je sais que
l'ambassadeur va monsieur l'ambassadeur
va avoir une réponse mais c'est aussi la
diplomatie c'est pas pouvoir répondre et
pas pouvoir mettre sur la place publique
tout ce qui est fait pour des raisons de
sécurité pour des raisons d'avancer de
négociation donc je remercie monsieur
lowrider de répondre mais je
comprendrais qu'il puisse pas répondre
en totalité mais je peux pas dire on
peut pas dire que la france n'a rien
fait je pense que la france c'est quand
même mobilisé et eu une réactivité
extrêmement importante et je l' ai vécu
moi-même donc je peux je peux en
témoigner je vous laisse répondre
monsieur merci madame la présidente pour
ma part je suis pas sûr d'avoir compris
la question mais par contre j'ai noté
beaucoup de choses dans votre propos
pour lesquels
je souhaite réagir d'abord à quel moment
avez vous entendu dire que la situation
humanitaire était pas grave à quel
moment avez vous entendu dire ça j'ai
dit le contraire et c'est même la raison
pour laquelle la france à dégager 100
millions d'euros donc ça excusez moi
mais
ça me rappelle exactement tout ce que je
dénonçais avant qui consiste à dire
excusez moi je vous dis je je crois vous
avoir écouté du début à la fin
donc je ça ça me je le ressens
exactement comme ceux que je n'ai pas
cessé de dénoncer avant c'est-à-dire des
tentative de culpabilisation ce que vous
avez dit exactement c'est 100 millions
d'euros connaissez vous un autre pays au
monde pour lequel la france la dégager
100 millions d'euros d'aidé humanitaire
cherchez bien 1er le temps
deuxièmement donc ce que fait la france
je crois vous avoir répondu
troisièmement sur les salaires et non
vous avez parlé de l'allemagne
l'allemagne en effet l'allemagne a donné
400 millions d'euros par an pendant 20
ans ou presque 20 ans la france n'a pas
donné à temps autant on n'a pas tout à
fait le même budget puisque nous avons
aussi d'autres priorités nous sommes
présents ailleurs dans le monde
mais enfin nous y avons mis beaucoup
d'hommes beaucoup de d'engagement on a
perdu 90 soldats en afghanistan donc je
pense que c'est pas du tout une bonne
idée décide comparer ce que fait
l'allemagne et la france je pense que
c'est pas une bonne idée
troisièmement les salaires les bataves
veulent payer les salaires oui je répète
ça n'est pas une bonne idée ce n'est pas
une bonne idée c'est exactement ce que
j'ai décrit tout à l'heure c'est à dire
que ce n'est plus de l'humanitaire que
de payer les salaires des profs c'est
pas de l'humanitaire c'est faire le
boulot du gouvernement à la place du
gouvernement et c'est ça qu'il faut pas
faire je pense maintenant si nos amis
bataves le faire si on va pas les en
empêcher mais moi je pense que ce qui
est plus important plutôt que payer les
salaires des profs qui vont aller
enseigner dans les écoles
le programme établi par les talibans et
dans des écoles ou les filles ne sont
pas
je pense que c'est pas ça qui va faire
moi je pense que ce qu'il faudrait qu'on
fasse c'est comme on l'a fait dans le
passé c'est d'essayer discrètement de
financer des écoles clandestines pour
les filles par exemple quatrièmement la
france et d'être absente je sais pas
s'il faut que je réponde enfin c'est ici
c'est votre question je ne suis pas sûr
de l'avoir caucus la france a été à
l'initiative des conditions qui ont été
fixées par la communauté internationale
dès août maintenant si vous pensez que
il faut dire ça et puis deux mois après
se débrouille se dépêcher de faire autre
chose alors pourquoi on a fixé des
conditions on a fixé des conditions on
s'y tient c'est nous n'avons pas besoin
d'eux ils ont besoin de nous
c'est surtout ça qu'il faut que les
talibans comprennent parce que comme on
leur a tout donné dans la négociation
depuis trois ans
eh bien ils ont perdu l'habitude qui
n'ont jamais eu par ailleurs de faire
des concessions j'attends qu'ils
comprendront pas la notion de rapport de
force eh bien il n'y a aucune chance
qu'il fasse des concessions il ya aucune
chance qu'ils évoluent il ya aucune
chance qu'ils changent leurs positions
sur les femmes si on leur donne tout
pourquoi ce qui changerait banon
d'ailleurs le ton
le ton est quand même effarant c'est
vous devez nous aider vous devez nous
aider non on ne doit pas les aider
excusez moi on ne doit pas les aider ça
n'empêche pas l'amitié séculaire est en
effet vous l'avais dit dès l'année
prochaine nous fêtons le centenaire de
la délégation archéologique française en
afghanistan
eh oui pendant un siècle la france à
financer des écoles la france à financer
des bourses jusqu'à est encore encore
aujourd'hui nous finançons des bourses
et nous allons continuer à avoir des
boursiers donc oui on continue mais
politiquement il faut être exigeant
pardonne-moi annick je voudrais juste
parce que évidemment ce n'est pas à lui
de dire mais en plus faible d'autant
moins vous laisser dire ça c'est que
monsieur l'ambassadeur était dans les
derniers à de nos deux des ambassadeurs
acp à partir après être sûr que les
évacuations ont pu être fait dans les
temps je peux vous dire que sa famille
tremblay aussi pour lui
et donc je pense qu'au contraire la
france a pu s'enorgueillir à ce moment
là d'être dans les derniers diplomates
à partir une soit sûr que les
évacuations soit faite de nos amis
afghans
merci alors j'ai plusieurs interventions
ce que je vous propose c'est que comme
le repas c'est que je crains qu'ils ont
beaucoup ma demande ensuite alors toutes
les personnes qui souhaitent réagir vont
le faire maintenant je souhaitais
également que madame liseron boudoul
qu'il n'a pas qui nous a vraiment
beaucoup parler de son vécu et de
l'institut en afghanistan puissent
réagir par rapport à tout ce qu'elle a
entendu si c'était possible et en
attendant qu'elle se prépare je vais
passer la parole à d'abord victoire
jasmin en suite vous madame qu'il avait
demandé ce qu il yad autres demandes
d'interventions non alors donc mais
n'est-ce pas madame beaudoin ensuite une
troisième et puis on merci merci
beaucoup madame la présidente merci à
vous tous et toutes il y avait pris la
parole au cours de ces différentes
tables rondes parce que c'est je ne peux
pas dire que c'est intéressant parce
qu'on parle de sujets qui est tellement
difficile
mais vous m'avez beaucoup apporter parce
que le cecos et de la délégation depuis
tantôt la présidente est ensemble du
bureau et tous les sénateurs et
sénatrices on vraiment dénoncer
c'est situation et là je suis vraiment
vraiment très touchés dont le tiens à
remercier particulièrement madame
liseron boudoul parce qu'être une femme
journaliste et être courageuse pour
aller et en afghanistan pour nous
montrer les images et c'est grâce aux
journalistes justement que nous
bénéficions des formations qui nous
permettent évidemment de comprendre la
situation des personnes qui vivent
là-bas et le courage aussi des femmes
africaines qui sont là il de tous ceux
qui ont
témoigné en fonction de leur fonction de
leur mission mais aussi ceux qui ont
vécu des choses difficiles mais ma
question madame google sait comment vous
faites pour séjourner pour rester pour
vivre 6e là bas parce que c'est
important pour nous d'avoir des
informations c'est vrai et c'est grâce
aux journalistes que nous qui sommes
très loin nous pouvons avoir des
informations et comment vous faites et
comment quelles sont les relations que
vous pouvez avoir à puiser de façon
apaisée avec les talibans il autre chose
j'ai vu enfin on a travaillé les autres
témoignages il ya par exemple une
famille entière
qui est décédée à cause de la fin par
manque de nutrition et vous avez aussi
montrer des exemples alors je voudrais
savoir comment on peut
répartir différemment parce que ça a été
dit dans le reportage la répartition des
aides parce que là le monsieur
l'ambassadeur et de d'évoquer des
actions qui sont mises en oeuvre à la
fois par la france mes parents de votre
pays mais comment on peut faire pour que
dans les régions les plus reculées
la population puisse bénéficier
de la nuit de la nourriture parce qu'en
fait on voit que de plus en plus les
filles sont vendus il a dans les
témoignages là ils ne valent
pratiquement rien en fait donc 16 et
l'âge c'est ça le plus douloureux dans
tout ce qu'on entend des pays qui sont
vendus
c'est ça c'est incroyable quand je vois
qu'un enfant de 9 ans est ici frais dans
le système on sait bien dans beaucoup de
pays dans la plupart des pays c'est
quand même un enfant qu'on
nourrit qu'on protège les danois dire
qu'on éduque et là c'est devenu de la
marchandise c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable donc c'est sûr tout cela donc
comment on peut faire pour éviter que
les gens aient à vendre leurs enfants
pour faire vivre le reste de leur
famille y compris les bébés mais c'est
le dramatique ce que j'entends ça dit
que là les problèmes de géopolitique
c'est la face et al l'inhumanité de
cette situation là voilà merci merci
chers collègues donc comme j'avais
l'intention de donner la parole à madame
oudoul derrière ça tombe très bien ça
sans m'entendre il ouais là la première
questions comme comment je fais pour
travailler je suis journaliste donc j'ai
l'habitude d'aller dans dans des zones
de crise et quand je suis arrivé à
kaboul pour la première fois c'était une
semaine exactement après la prise de
pouvoir des talibans donc un dimanche le
22 août j'y suis resté à peu près un
mois et là j'y suis retourné ces deux
dernières semaines pour réaliser ce
reportage sur la crise humanitaire et
d'autres sur les femmes et sur sur la
vie en ce moment tout simplement des
afghans à kaboul mais pas seulement pour
aller en afghanistan il déjà il faut
arriver à trouver le moyen d'y aller ce
qu'il n'y a pas de ligne
commerciale encore d'avions donc il
ya plusieurs options mais c'est déjà
très compliquée pour se retrouver sur
place après il faut une autorisation de
travail des talibans comme dans beaucoup
de pays dans le monde il se trouve que
depuis le 15 août les talibans sont
plutôt très ouvert
à l'aja c'est bon donc il nous accueille
d'une façon assez correct
je parle de nous la presse
internationale ils n'ont pas tout à fait
le même genre de réaction avec la presse
nationale surtout lorsqu elles couvrent
des événements comme des manifestations
de femmes dont kaboul dans d'autres
villes
maintenant ils commencent j'ai constaté
cette fois ci qui il commence à demander
un peu plus de regard sur nous ce qu'on
fait parce que je pense qu'ils se sont
rendus compte que la plupart des
journalistes internationaux qui étaient
venues depuis
fin août début septembre
ne ne faisait pas que des reportages
positif pour pour eux et donc ça
commence un petit peu à les énerver donc
ça complexifie un peu notre façon de
travailler sur le terrain mais pour le
moment je dois dire que ils m'ont laissé
travailler dans une relative liberté
donc voilà je tiens aussi à porter moi
je n'ai pas d' analyses politiques sur
ce contexte je ne peux que vous parler
de ce que je vis et avec certaines
nuances aussi parce que j'ai rencontré
des talibans bien sûr puisque ça fait
partie de mon travail sur place si on y
rencontrer au qatar et j'en ai rencontré
à kaboul
je constate que
il ya beaucoup de personnes très
différentes au sein des talibans ce
n'est pas un groupe homogène il ya des
personnes avec qui on peut parler de
tout y compris du travail des femmes et
j'ai entendu de certains talibans très
haut placé qui parle un anglais très
correct d'ailleurs qui qui ont voyagé
qui ont négocié d'ailleurs avec les
américains depuis deux ans et qui m'ont
dit qu'ils n'étaient pas du tout opposée
au travail de femmes dans certaines
conditions toujours pareil on va pas les
faire devenir des grands démocrates ce
sont des religieux islamistes
extrémistes
mais je pense que ils ne sont pas les
mêmes que ceux d'il ya 20 ans
contrairement à ce que vous pensez
monsieur martin ont je pense que
certains talibans ont changé et qu'ils
savent que surtout que la société
afghane a changé et qu'il ne pond et
qu'ils ne vont pas pouvoir leur faire
faire ce qu'ils ont pu leur demander de
faire il ya vingt ans maintenant chez
les talibans il ya les religieux les
ultra religieux les extrémistes les
guerriers les combattants ceux qui
pensent qu'ils pensent religion ceux qui
pensent communauté internationale ce
qu'ils pensent ouverture au monde ceux
qui pensent business voilà il ya
différents types de talibans et pour le
moment il ya de grands débats et de
grands conflits entre eux
ce qu'on voit effectivement à l'heure
actuelle
ne donne pas beaucoup de signes positifs
mais eux quand on leur pose des
questions vous disent qu'ils ont la
pression déjà de faire des efforts merci
c'est exactement ce que je
peux vous disent qu'ils font déjà des
efforts par exemple il vous donne un
exemple
après chacun analyse mais moi je vous
parle de ce que j'ai entendu de leur
voix ils vous disent que
les femmes peuvent aller les étudiants
ne peuvent retourner dans certaines
universités
pas les publics pour le moment mais
enfin ils nous disent qu'ils vont les
rouvrir bientôt dans certaines
universités que j'ai visités à kaboul
effectivement j'ai rencontré des
étudiantes qui revenait en cour pas très
nombreuses parce que il ya toujours
cette peur obsédante un peu partout
d'être arrêté par un groupe de talibans
à check point qui serait un peu plus
rigoureux sur leurs vêtements sur le
fait qu'elle ne sont pas cons compreniez
d'un ce qu'on appelle un mâle protecteur
enfin chapron voilà rien dans
l'afghanistan des talibans rien n'est
clair en ce moment y compris leurs
mesures y compris leur décision certains
vous disent qu'ils vont y réfléchisse à
ouvrir le monde du travail nouveau
femmes d'autres où vous disent que c'est
déjà bien qu'elle puisse retravailler
dans les hôpitaux ce que j'ai constaté
ce qui est vrai et dans l'hôtellerie ce
qui est vrai aussi et dans l'aéroport
puisque là pour la première fois j'ai
été fouillé par par des par des employés
femme à qui les talibans ont recommandé
de venir travailler donc je pense qu'ils
avancent aussi je suis pas en train du
tout de les défendre mais il avance
aussi avec leur mode de pensée avec la
pression qu'on met sur eux et ça il faut
la maintenir la pression j'en suis sûr
maintenant s'engager dans des
discussions avec eux ça ne veut pas
forcément dire reconnaître politiquement
les talibans ça veut dire essayer de
leur expliquer travailler discuter
mettre des conditions à tel ou tel
apport de dead
répondre à leur demande aussi mais en
leur faisant comprendre que le monde de
maintenant n'est pas le monde d'avant et
je pense que certains d'entre eux
sont d'accord avec ce type de réflexion
et de comportements
diplomate à avoir voilà ce que je peux
vous dire
sur
la dernière question qui était la vôtre
l'aide humanitaire
c'est très compliqué parce qu'il ya des
ong qui ne veulent pas revenir pour des
questions de sécurité j'ai discuté avec
médecins sans frontières
qui n'a pas quitté l'afghanistan qui est
toujours resté depuis le 15 août mais
eux ont des quand même des mesures de
vie très strictes à respecter parce
qu'en plus dans des eaux dans certaines
zones la présence de dèche
est confirmée donc ça peut encore plus
de complications parce que les ong se
disent comme nous les journalistes enfin
nous on fait un peu moins attention
conditions de sécurité
les ong se disent faudrait pas qu'ils
aient un kidnapping de deux membres de
travailleurs humanitaires voir un
assassinat avoir un attentat une attaque
donc ça complexifie aussi encore plus
l'apport de l'aide dans ce pays en ce
moment puisqu'on sait que les attaques
de des chants repris et la priorité des
talibans pour l'instant
c'est en tout cas ce qu'ils m'ont dit
tous à tous les niveaux
c'est là la lutte contre des juges
et je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas d'autres priorités pour le
moment l'organisation de la vie publique
la font petit à petit à leur manière
mais encore une fois ça dépendra aussi
de ce que de ce que nous pouvons avoir
comme pression sur eux pour les faire
changer je pense qu'il ne faut pas rond
pour les canaux de discussion
voilà
merci madame boudoul donc je vais passer
la parole à madame faille mais robiolle
et ensuite à madame grille a
enfin nommé rubio l'uefa à madame la
présidente je serais très très rapide
pour apporter deux informations
voilà
merci madame présidente pour m'avoir
donné à nouveau la parole je vais dire
deux mots très court très court en ce
qui concerne ce qui vient d'être dit par
madame salim en effet il est lui-même on
sait pas ce qu'elle fait en afghanistan
moi je peux vous dire avec des contacts
que j'ai avec des femmes leaders afghane
pour celles qui sont restées le 5
décembre via une délégation des femmes
afghanes qui vont aller au pakistan
organisé par youngman pour négocier avec
les talibans il est de même un petit peu
cette cette façon de faire pour dire à
tout prix il faut faire tout avec
n'importe quelle condition et un défi
pour nous est d'un or a demandé à ses
employés mal
à les retourner au travail en demandant
aux femmes de rester au travail à
distance or on sait très bien que l'aide
internationale et humanitaire doit être
aux
arrivées au fond d'eux mêmes et ça cette
aide pour arriver pas des femmes et non
pas par des hommes qui n'ont pas eu la
même
les mêmes connaissances du terrain etc
et enfin je termine avec le faites vos
madame madame la ministre vien encore
des athlètes paralympiques qui sont là
bas qui me demande tous les jours tous
les jours s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît nous aider et la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'à travers de tout ce qu'on est
en train de faire c'est la jeunesse
française qui en train
s'appropriait et cet élan de solidarité
avec avec l'état elle avec le peuple
afghan et demain soir il va avoir un
concert à science
les fonds vont être
destiné aux femmes et aux filles
afghanes merci merci beaucoup madame
donc la dernière intervention de la part
de madame shoukria haïdar et donc
ensuite on conclura cette matinée riche
en échanges avec des avis parfois un
petit peu nuancé oui
bah écoute et merci à nouveau devant
dans le temps d'un départ émettra ses
coûts
concernant les négociations de paix ou
doux d'avant l'ouverture de discuter
avec les talibans tout d'abord je
remercie madame un d'autres attention de
votre courage d'aller en encaissant des
apporter tous ces témoignages que
je suis en relation avec toutes ces
femmes qui fait de manifestations
qu'elles sont vraiment ravi qui vous
êtes vous et comme vous les journalistes
arrivent auprès d'eux et de transmettre
leurs paroles maintenant quand on l'a
déjà durant toutes ces années de
négociations avec les talibans c'est en
perte de temps et nuit
on l'a poussée des manières
vraiment
phénoménal haut niveau sur la scène
internationale
maintenant
les talibans sont différents tout le
monde est différent mais
ça vous le savez très bien et nous le
savons parce que moi je suis afghane
depuis 96 94 que les talents qui ont
émergé
je suis je le regarde je le suis un jour
pas genre
les talibans n'ont pas changé elles
savent très bien avec avec vous dans
cette période que le monde ne la
reconnaisse pas comment vous
entourer et quoi dire comment dire il ya
parmi eux des gens dès qu'ils savent
très bien parlé ils sont très
aimablement ça c'est sûr mais aussi
comment vous utilisez dans les sphères
comme ici de nous de nous apporter les
paroles de paix retrouvée un petit pot
dans le sens est
calme et la
position
à mon avis elle est important
je sais que cette négociation cette
ouverture des paroles ce alors dans
l'espace ça danse ça le temps qu'on perd
c'est l'usure c'est dans l'usure qui
sautent gagner il faut qu'ils en soient
enfin merci
là dessus il faut pas se faire
des idées qui vont changer et ne
changeront jamais merci merci beaucoup
madame alors il est temps de conclure
cette matinée qui a été longue et riche
deschamps je remercie vraiment les les
trois
sénatrice qui ont piloté ces tables
rondes à la fois laurence cohen nantais
j'avais et le rôle lors laure darcos
pardon on a beaucoup de laurence dans la
délégation je voulais appeler laurence
donc et je confirme que laure darcos et
bien sénatrice de l'essonne
voilà il ya eu un petit switch tout à
l'heure avec le finistère mais qui était
aussi un très beau département je
voudrais sur ces quelques mots qui un
peu léger vous dire combien c'était
important pour la délégation aux droits
des femmes d'organiser cette table ronde
ce matin le 25 novembre journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes on a mené de
nombreux travaux la délégation sur le
droit des femmes sur l'égalité on avait
aussi mené des travaux sur les femmes
armes de guerre et la situation vous
nous avez décrit les et on n'est pas
arrivé ce matin sans information on
avait moi j'avais déjà vu votre
reportage madame boudoul qui m'avait
déjà beaucoup choqué mais on a eu
énormément d'informations jusqu alors
sur l'état
des femmes la situation des femmes en
afghanistan mais pas que et je crois que
ce qui est important aussi ce que je
retiendrai de cette matinée c'est que si
on veut si on agit sur le droit des
femmes en afghanistan on va aussi
améliorer la situation des hommes et des
femmes aujourd'hui et vous avez eu cette
cette intelligence aussi à madame
boudoul de parler finalement deux
d'élargir le sujet en réalité et nous on
le sait à la délégation lorsqu on
progresse sur les droits des femmes on
progresse pour les hommes et pour les
femmes et vous avez cet éclairage je
vous en remercie donc il est urgent qu
on reste mobilisé la seule difficulté
c'est qu'on a vu il y avait et oui des
nuances dans vos propos une manière
d'appréhender
le sujet différentes et c'est normal
chacun à son vécu pour tous les sujets
c'est la même chose monsieur
l'ambassadeur a eu cette vision et
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi avait les
mains dans le cambouis
en planète et donc c'était aussi une
situation d'urgence à gérer avec des
difficultés
extrêmement forte donc de la nuance la
seule chose on sait que là la vie
aujourd'hui des femmes afghanes des
afghans n'est pas nuancé donc ça c'est
une réalité donc on se doit de rester
mobilisées pour que ces femmes et ces
filles et bien ne subissent pas ce
qu'elles ont pu subir à d'autres
périodes est ce que d'autres femmes
subissent dans le monde il faut que ça
reste visible il ne faut pas qu'elle
soit invisible et nous à la délégation
des femmes ont souhaité est
véritablement donné cette visibilité ce
matin avec vous toutes et vous tous les
intervenants que ce soit marie george
buffet est aussi député qui a pris à
bras le corps aussi cette cette
problématique donc je vais pas tellement
être plus long je retiens évidemment la
question
la manière de porter
le sujet avec le sport je dois dire que
en début de semaine il ya les séances de
qi âgées j'avais imaginé une question
sur cette femme qui fait du tennis et
qui avait disparu en chine la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est que l'information est
heureusement il ya des journalistes qui
font leur travail l'information que nous
avions sur cette femme est assez limitée
à ce stade puisque
ben voilà on sait qu'il ya des
difficultés donc faire entendre la
parole c'est une chose est donc merci de
donner la parole à ces femmes à ses
hommes pour qu'on comprenne ce qui se
passe est donc véritablement
merci pour ce temps des changes à tous
et à toutes et on va continuer et voir
comment on peut réussir à attirer
l'attention du grand public des
politiques du gouvernement
parce que le gouvernement a fait et va
continuer à faire et je remercie à tous
et je vous souhaite une bonne journée
malgré ce sujet grave dans une autre
dont nous avons prêté ce matin